how do you know when a movie is ready to
be made ah so it's a great question how
do you know when a movie is ready to be
made I I think there are always a series
process of steps you kind of go through
right and the part of that is your
relationship as a producer with your
director that you need to feel that
they've thought it through fully right
so it's not just that the choices that
you make but what you're choosing not to
do too so you have to kind of work
through a process of finding a common
language of finding what really matters
like we need this we need beauty here we
need a transit transitional moment here
we need to make sure the plot works it
kind of that that construction both of
the script the the bigger meanings
behind the film the values the
references the the visual language how
are you developing those two things in
partnership right and not just
partnership with you is the director and
the producer its partnership between the
entire team right so after that process
of going through development you know I
think that often in development that
language gets set right so when you get
your script ready and you feel those
moments of their you're starting to then
go out and and prepare the you know get
the cast get the the money in those
instances but there's a at that point so
level of surface right that you've done
not the big deep dive once you start
bringing your team the DP the designer
the editor the composer the costume
designer the ad you're doing much more
deeper dive really looking at those and
prioritizing those right because you
kind of want to walk through you the the
decision-making process before you get
to set right
what matters what are the things we
can't let go once you've waited those
and prioritize those and you feel your
team knows it I think that ultimately
and this is why you need time and
something we've lost I think in the
crunch of making beautiful work for less
money you know as we've all had demands
to reduce our budgets time is the first
thing that gets sacrificed and when you
sacrifice time you're also sacrificing
serendipity right you're sacrificing how
do we engineer the miraculous to happen
when we have so much to do right
thinking it through I think it's kind of
that process of how you go from
definition right what is it we want to
achieve to prioritization which is
ultimately managing complexity right so
how do we let's call it discovery to
managing complexity to engineering
serendipity you know that process at the
kind of three step process only once we
reach to that point can you say are we
ready to shoot but the challenge of that
is you often don't even get that luxury
right that now people saying okay you're
ready you ready to make your movie
you've got your cast you got your money
shooting five weeks all right that's all
the money you're going to get and to
work through that discovery
prioritization management you don't have
the time so when you want to add in that
thing that lifts what will be good work
to great work good luck you know that's
that's part of the challenge we're
living in right now
you